一步红楼梦到近封建贵族的盛衰。曹雪芹的文笔厉害之处,在运描写荣国府的盛衰时,凌阳挂脚无忌可寻。一些看似不齐眼的细节中,往往藏着波涛凶有的答案。
原住第四十回,家母周代劉老老近大观园游玩,第一站是林黛玉的销相馆。
林走前,家母发现销相馆的窗沙颜色有些成就,便让王府人即时更换,由此找出了陈风多年的上等侠影杀。
鳳姐一面说,早命人取了一匹来了,家母说,可不是这个,先时原不过是胡窗帝,后来我们拿这个做背做帐子,试试也尽好,没人就找出几匹来,拿银红的替他胡窗子,鳳姐答应着,众人都看了称赞不已。
销影杀是一个非常重要的道具,用以皆是假假的衰败。
家母当年价径容国府时,销影杀这种步料被用来胡窗户,从用途来看,销影杀的地位似乎不是很高,在家母那个时代,他只能充当遮风的窗沙,可草血请紧接着就展开反转,接开销影杀的真面目。
气急是王西奉,他之前从未见过俩银杀,如今听家母一说,立刻拉着自己衣服的步料,与俩银杀展开对比,不比不知道,一比下一跳,原住是如此描述的。
奉剑忙把自己身上穿的一件大红棉杀傲子惊拉了出来,向家母削一骂道,看我的这傲,家母削一骂都说,这也是上好的了,这是如今的上用内造的,竟比不上这个,奉剪道,这个薄片子还说是上用内造呢,竟连观用的也比不上了。
王西奉身上的杀傲用的是上用内造的步料,可家母削一骂打眼一球,就知道只量远不如俩银杀。
王西奉不由发出感看说,如今的上用内造,竟连当年的观用也比不上了。
经非西比的情况不止出现在步料上,红楼梦后文也有相同的情况。
原住地七十七回,王西奉生病,虚用人生唯一。
王夫任各处寻找,终于从家母那里找到一根上好的人生。
可一年代太沉,早已没有了要效,王夫任只能自行花钱,伟托需保差从府外进行采购。
无论是当年的俩银杀,还是人生,他们的品象都是上好的,如今哪怕花钱都难能寻到。
通过这种物品的经非西比,来硬趁如今的荣国府,远远比不上当年的鼎盛时期。
家母作为当年鼎盛时期的遗产,他的许多生活习惯还继续鼎成当年的荣光。
如今,上用内造都比不上的俠银杀,被他拿来当窗杀史。
又令人找出一些清杀,做成家备心给腰患门纯。
看见如此奢侈的生活,草血请给我等独者安排了一个嘴剃事人物,便是刘老老。
当看见如此珍贵的杀料,进拿来胡窗子,刘老老说出了独者们的心声。
他说,我们想他做衣盛也不能,拿着胡窗子起不可惜。
我们很难则怪家母,他从荣福鼎盛时期生活而来,保留了那个时代的生活习惯,这是无可厚非的。
而通过这种惊妃西比的衰败,草血请揭露了荣辱无常的道理。
许多红楼爱好者喜欢探头假家的旧王之道,若是原非不死,假家没有失去政治扣山,便能继续欣盛。
又或者驻中子孙教育,将假真、假脸、假宝育都培养成凶怀大致的动粮之才,是否假家就不会摔败。
草血请给出的答案是不。
原住第五回,您荣二宫很请仅换仙子,点画家宝御时曾说过。
无家自国朝定鼎以来,公民意识富贵传流,虽利百年,耐运中书禁,不可晚回者。
再有第五回,请可请林中向王西奉托梦,奉借寻问可有勇宝无语之法。
可请听完冷笑一声说,甚自好吃野,脾气太来,容辱自古周儿富时,起人里能可保长的。
但如今能与容时,仇化下将来衰时的事业,亦可为长宝勇权了。
请可请知道,根本没有所谓的长盛不衰,有新盛就会有衰落。
他唯一能做的就是盯住王西奉。
在如今还算新盛之时,提前为以后的衰落做好准备。
以此官周多红楼爱好者提出的解决之法。
袁妃不死,假家就不会衰落吗?
又或者说,袁妃迟早会红。
他红了之后,假家又能去一靠哪个政治靠山呢?
真的会有无限的政治靠山,再等着假家吗?
若是注重死孙教育,将假真、假脸、假宝育培养成动粮之采,
可下一代人还会是动粮之采吗?
又或者说,假家能保证每一代假家人都是标准的动粮之采吗?
连皇家教育都会有披露,遇养出婚绝。
各个朝代也有三百年大线,假家真的能次次逃过衰败的命运吗?
恐怕不能。
心胜之所以为心胜,就是因为有衰败做对比。
太阳东升西洛,而不会永远高高挂在头顶之上。
容辱如影随行,道料为胜一场空,
总居红楼不过一场梦。
朝学秦传达的,或许不是消极的虚无主义,
而是,从如两相望,所欲随心安的获达心境,
以此与诸君共免。
今天的红楼解读就聊到这里,我们下个视频再会。